à votre avis entre un homme et une femme
quel candidat a le plus de chances
d'être élu au québec selon notre analyse
l'un et l'autre ont exactement les mêmes
chances aujourd'hui mais on est partis
de loin avant d'en arriver là nous avons
compilé tous les résultats électoraux
depuis le 25 avril 1940
c'est à partir de ce moment là que les
femmes ont gagné le droit de voter et de
se présenter aux scrutins provinciaux
lors des années 40 et 50
aucune femme ne remporte d'élections les
chances d'une candidate sont nuls
en revanche un homme candidat avait une
chance sur trois d'être élu la situation
s'améliore à partir des années 60
lorsque pour la première fois des
candidates remportent leur bataille
électorale lors des années 60 70 et 80
une candidate a alors une chance sur
huit de gagner un siège à l'assemblée
nationale mais un candidat avec une
chance sur quatre était quand même en
meilleure posture
c'est finalement à partir des années 90
que les chances des hommes et des femmes
deviennent équivalente
depuis environ 30 ans l'écart est comblé
un candidat est une candidate ont chacun
une chance sur six d'être choisi par les
québécois donc ce ne sont pas les
électeurs qui empêche la teinte d'une
zone paritaire chez les élus une fois
devant les urnes et citoyens votent
autant pour des hommes que pour les
femmes
le problème c'est que pour chaque femme
qui se présente environ deux hommes en
font autant
mais la situation est sur le point de
changer
le prochain scrutin promet d'être
historique avec un nombre record de
candidatures féminines
est-ce que 2018 sera l'année de la
parité en politique au québec
la réponse le 1er octobre